what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today was the finale
of the falcon and the winter soldier
series on disney plus
and i want to know what you thought
about it so rate this episode out of 10
in the comments down below and did you
like this more than
less than or just about the same as you
liked one division
let me know down below this is going to
be my ending explained and post
credit scene explained for the finale of
the falcon and the winter soldier
so needless to say yet i'll say it
anyways spoilers are coming up
and if you haven't yet entered my
captain america shield giveaway you can
find the details in the description of
this video
so let's break down what just happened
in the finale of the falcon and the
winter soldier
starting with that post credit scene now
as we learned in this series sharon
carter was never pardoned for what she
did during civil war
she got sam his wings back and she got
captain america
steve rogers his shield back she was
then marked enemy of the state and has
been on the run ever since
then in this episode we found out that
she was in fact
the power broker and not to brag but i
did call that right after
episode 2. so sharon carter was the
mysterious power broker and we were kind
of hoping that she would turn out to be
good but according to this post-credit
scene
that is not the case in fact her whole
plan helping bucky and sam
was actually to get pardoned so she
could learn inside information about the
government so that's what she did she
helped sam and bucky and then she had a
hearing in which
the government apologized for what they
did to her and they pardoned her and
welcomed her back
they also essentially gave her her old
job back at the cia
calling her once again agent carter but
as she leaves
while everybody is clapping for her we
kind of see this little evil look go
on her face this is later confirmed to
be an evil look when she ends up making
a phone call
she tells this person on the other line
to start lining up her buyers because
they're about to have full access to
government secrets
prototype weapons and more she's now
working for the cia
and she has access to some pretty juicy
stuff and
this was her plan all along help bucky
and sam so she could get pardoned and
then have
access to all of these things because
she had no intention on giving up being
the power broker which is a pretty big
twist
but it seems like she's built quite the
life for herself in magiport as the
power broker and even though her country
has now pardoned her
which was her whole plan all along she
hasn't exactly pardoned her country for
what they did to her
because she feels like she was treated
very very unfairly and has lost hope in
her own
government so she has taken things into
her own hands and is now the very
powerful
power broker the big question now is who
is she talking to
on the other line it could simply be her
assistant which we saw in episode 3
or maybe perhaps it's valentina we know
she's up to something with zemo and john
walker perhaps sharon carter is mixed in
there as well as the power broker
we may not know now but it definitely
seems like sharon carter is going to be
returning in a future mcu project or
projects as the power broker and this
story is far from over
and now let's jump into the ending of
the falcon and the winter soldier finale
of course we pick up where we left off
in episode 5 the flag smashers have
infiltrated the grc
the global repatriation council and they
are voting on whether or not to send
refugees back to their own countries
from which they fled from the flax
masters want a world without borders
a world without flag so of course they
want to stop this vote and how they plan
to stop the vote is to take
the members of the grc hostage they
start to evacuate the grc building but
the flax masters have secretly
infiltrated so the people who they think
are helping them are actually the flag
smashers kind of sending them to their
doom
but the heroes show up sam and bucky
show up and also
sharon carter who does help but as we
learn she has her own agenda she's
helping so she can get pardoned and get
access to government secrets and weapons
sam shows up and we see his awesome new
captain america
suit with his brand new vibranium wings
from wakanda
the wings were in the case that sam was
opening at the end of episode 5 and this
was a favor that bucky called in from
the wakandans the suit is very comic
accurate and he has now become captain
america he is no longer falcon and we
even hear him
call himself captain america play that
clip here
while a bunch of fighting is happening
the flag smashers take the members of
the grc hostage and they decide that
it's actually time to kill them they
want to prove their point and hopefully
spark some change in the world
but as they decide to do this john
walker shows up with a new captain
america shield that was
nothing like the vibranium shield that
he used to have that sam now has
but he shows up and he starts to
actually kick some butt
he defeats a few flag smashers and
almost defeats carly but in the end
he makes a decision and actually redeems
himself
instead of going after carly at the end
to try and kill her he actually makes
the decision to try
and save some people from here he would
actually go on to fight alongside bucky
and sam who of course is now the new
captain america
john walker has thrown his makeshift
shield away and has actually accepted
sam
as the new captain america and then at
the end he goes on to become
us agent just like he does in the comics
and as we can see here he is rocking an
extremely comic accurate us agent
uniform
so we have not seen the end of john
walker unfortunately
the person that gave him this new suit
and has deemed him
u.s agent is valentina otherwise known
in the comics as madame
hydra unfortunately we're unsure of
valentina at the moment is she bad
is she madame hydra just like she is in
the comics or could she perhaps be
working for thunderbolt ross
more on that in just a bit we go on of
course to find out that sharon carter is
actually the power broker she hired
bartrock the leaper but she kills him
because
he tries to blackmail her but she gets
shot by carly then carly and sam fight
until sharon eventually shoots and kills
carly which means that the two people
who knew she was the power broker
are dead zemo stated in a previous
episode that he knew of the power broker
but didn't know who
he or she was so i'm guessing that a lot
of people don't know that she is the
power broker especially not sam
or bucky or the us government for that
matter but this is actually why she
kills carly because she can't have carly
telling sam that she's the power broker
after carly dies sam takes her out to
some paramedics where a bunch of
newscasters are around
filming the senators from the grc
council are there and sam makes a very
heartfelt speech about
not sending away the refugees and about
helping the world
and not being against each other we
learned that the speech actually worked
on the council and they decided to not
send the refugees back
and it looks like it also worked on a
lot of people as a lot of people have
embraced
sam as the new captain america however
at this time the flag smashers have been
taken
into custody these are the super soldier
flag smashers not the civilians that
chose to follow them and help them out
the police are taking them away and
we're led to believe that they're
actually about to escape as one of the
swat members says the flag smashers
motto
one world one people however that is not
the case as they all die
in an explosion we cut to somebody in a
car who has just hit a detonator and
this
is actually zemo's butler we were
introduced to him in episode 3.
so in reality it's actually zemo who
killed the remaining flag smashers or at
least his butler did under his
instructions and he killed them to
finish his job
to take out all of the super soldiers
however he did not finish this job
completely we heard an agent tell sam
that there was actually a flag smasher
a super soldier flag smasher in the
ocean so there is at least
one more left and probably more even if
we don't count bucky and john walker who
are both super soldiers
now after the explosion we cut to
valentina who calls
zemo a friend and it seems like she
actually helped zemo blow up the flag
smashers so
she's up to no good but the big question
is is she up to no good
to do good or to do bad because
you can get rid of the bad guys by not
playing by the rules but you could also
get rid of some good guys along the way
we'll have to wait and see but she will
be showing up in the black
widow movie this is confirmed so we're
going to be learning a lot more about
her
pretty soon we then go to bucky making
amends with yori
at least doing his part to try and make
amends with yori
yori had been wondering what happened to
his son who died he believed that it was
more than what the police told him and
this has been haunting him because he
didn't really have any closure about it
bucky had been trying to make amends
with him but never could until now
he tells him that his son was murdered
by the winter soldier and that that
was him yori asks why and bucky tells
him i didn't have a choice and this is
because he was brainwashed by hydra
at that point and under their control we
end bucky's story with him crossing out
all of the names on his book of amends
leaving it with dr raynor at the end
thanking her for everything that she did
for him
and then we have a very heartfelt ending
with isaiah bradley where sam says that
he's going to fight for his country and
be
a black captain america he then takes
isaiah and his grandson elijah to the
captain america memorial and we see that
sam had a memorial put in for
isaiah so everyone will know and never
forget what isaiah did for his country
and if we freeze frame here we can
actually see what the memorial says
and it says isaiah bradley is an
american hero whose name went unknown
for too long
isaiah was one of a dozen african
american soldiers who were recruited
against their will
and without their consent for
participation in human testing in
pursuit of the super soldier serum
most did not survive the few who lived
through testing were sent on secret
missions during the korean war
during the conflict against all odds
isaiah bradley rescued his fellow
soldiers and
28 other pows or prisoners of
war from behind enemy lines however
fearful of the ramifications of a black
super soldier
some individuals within the government
tried to erase isaiah's story from
history
his family was issued a falsified death
certificate
and for decades the truth of his
unflinching bravery was buried
sam says now they'll never forget what
you did for this country and
isaiah embraces him with love and thanks
that people will now know
everything that he went through for the
country and then the series ends with a
feel-good scene back in new orleans with
sam's family and his community with
bucky alongside as well
so what does this mean for the future of
the mcu
well sam is now captain america so we
definitely have not seen the end of
him he will most likely go on to lead
the new avengers team
this team will consist of characters
that we already know like spider-man
doctor strange
wanda and some new characters coming in
as well possibly she-hulk
moon knight and many other new
characters sam will most likely be the
leader of this new team
sharon carter is also about to stir up
some trouble she is the power broker
and extremely powerful person in
madrapore but is now
working for the cia and has access to a
lot of their secrets
secrets that she is planning on selling
so this story is definitely going to be
addressed
later on down the road and this could
possibly lead us to the thunderbolts or
the dark avengers forming or perhaps
maybe both
after all zemo is in the raft a place
that thunderbolt ross actually has
control over perhaps thunderbolt ross is
going to get zemo and the others that
are in that maximum security prison
and form his thunderbolts team either
way we have not seen the end of
a lot of these characters from the
falcon and the winter soldier
the president of marvel studios has
already said that what happens in these
shows does take place in the mcu and
will lead into
movies so don't worry if you love the
falcon and the winter soldier
these characters are not done yet but in
the meantime
let me know what you thought about the
finale and what you thought about the
series as a whole
in the comments down below don't forget
to subscribe for more marvel content
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof